[Music]
thousands gathered outside the supreme
court on tuesday afternoon to protest
the leaked draft opinion that was
reported to have the support of five
conservative justices an opinion that
concludes that since those who wrote the
constitution did not explicitly protect
women's reproductive rights then
previous judgments enshrining a woman's
right to choose had no basis in the law
i thought we were long past that point
i thought we it was protested about how
many decades ago but
it's
terrifying
just a handful of anti-abortion rights
protesters are outside the court too i
say abortion is murder but for those
seeking to end abortion access this has
been the goal since 1973
when justices ruled in favor of women's
reproductive rights in the case of roe v
wade justice roberts said that that was
an authentic draft so we're very happy
to hear that and we're hopeful that the
high court will stay with that draft and
that will be the decision to overturn
versus wade
the white house says it is prepared for
whatever the actual verdict is but the
president warned that the reasoning
underpinning the draft opinion has
far-reaching implications it basically
says
all the decisions related to your
private life
who you marry
whether or not you decide to conceive a
child or not whether or not you can have
an abortion a range of other decisions
whether or not how you raise your child
what does this do
and does this mean that in florida they
can decide they're going to pass a law
saying that same-sex marriage is not
permissible
the u.s has the worst maternal mortality
rate in the industrialized world those
here are worried that terrible metric
could now deteriorate even further the
sign was inspired by conversations with
many women today i don't think that
anybody has an idea of what the real
world consequences are and especially
those who are in a position of privilege
like everybody on the supreme court
myself included in that
there's a lot of
really potential for harm but there was
hope too the polls have consistently
shown 70 percent of americans are
against outlawing abortion the democrats
seem to be hoping for a bump in voter
turnout in november's midterm elections
from those who support female
reproductive rights but there is an
awareness here that in the past when the
democrats about the opportunity
to codify a woman's right to choose they
failed to do so
shia britancy al jazeera washington